let's try and win a game this stream
there's three minutes left in the
tournament
okay let's play a stafford maybe i'll
play a stafford
or not a stafford but maybe a stafford
d3 is like it's a super safe move
usually people who play d3 on move three
won't end up taking
but they might okay so we're getting
we're getting a transposition wow it's a
stafford
also i've been brewing my tea for the
last half hour
i have nice tea tonight i have um
this roasted
roasted dandelion root
it sounds weird but it's um it's nice
um just remembering my yeah so queen d4
is my preparedness
is so calming
yeah yeah i enjoy the late night streams
um did one last night it was
only just over an hour but it's nice to
oh what's the line here my g4
this is still prep actually nice to wind
down with some chests at the end of the
day
so this is actually my prep for magnus
carlsen
i prepared this line because he he
played this like d3 bishop e2 mover to
move order once in the the stafford i
don't think he would play g3 though
because queen jig's g3 is made in two
um so that was nice
hey the game finished before the
tournament ended
what were the odds this is also
so this is one of the traps that
everyone used to fall for
um even though we have like a small
variation of this trap
um can i
if you go to my youtube channel and you
go to videos
sort by most popular
uh you can kind of see the arrows of the
thumbnail
resemble the position that we just had
yeah 3.4 million views man
yeah that's why and this position is
white um
g3 it's not an effective way of
defending against a mating threat and i
should explain
there are a lot of comments on this
video why
the pawn can't take the queen but the
pawn is pinned in this variation
um so f takes g3 is illegal
so in this position the best move
the best move is actually kind of hard
to find
um but the best move does give white an
advantage
so white to move here what's the best
move in the position
[Music]
[Music]
i have a wedding in june which i'm a
best man for so uh but let's get to this
position
so there are a few comments uh saying f4
which would be a nice move but it's not
legal because that pawn still pinned
yeah maybe a few comments saying g3
didn't didn't just see what happened
opponent just played g3 walks into
maiden two
f pawn is pinned um
i'm going through the moves that don't
work first d4 it does block the bishop
but it doesn't block the queen
so this is a main threat another move
that
uh that looks okay bishop takes g4 is
probably the second best move
um if we analyze here
yeah black it's not completely winning
but it's it's pleasant for black with
attack
and d4 bishop b6 it's it's just
unpleasant for white
uh so the best move is
e5 good job i know a lot of people we're
saying e5
and the point of this move is to bait
it's either to bait the knight to e5 or
the queen
to the e file so if the light goes to e5
then there's d4
um which i think wins a piece right
yeah white's just winning here and if
queen takes e5 then bishop takes g4 is
more powerful because it threatens
rookie
e1 and if takes rookie one wins the
queen
stockfish will actually give plus three
here uh i do have like a kind of
deep prepared line which i would say
is not entirely plus three um
it actually starts after knight takes f2
wait no what's my preparation oh it
might be bishop f2
yeah it's bishop f2 never mind bishop f2
uh we check the king and then we take so
we get the rook for it
and then takes takes um
i can actually take here because the
knight's trapped and takes takes
and engine will give plus three but
from a practical standpoint uh i mean
black can still fight
you take the pawn you have rook and
actually yeah just rook for bishop and
knight so it's subjectively better for
white
but um that's why like when i play
stafford
uh i usually try and play it in more
like quick
time controls so if i get to this
position at the very least i would have
a time advantage
so just a little bit of prep and if
white doesn't play e5 then white's worse
so it's an added bonus
actually if white doesn't play c3 i
think light's worse
like the other moves are playable but
they lead to
like really strong attacks for black so
that's a tricky line why does the pawn
not take the knight initially
oh that's actually a good question too
uh
if pawn takes yeah maybe some people are
suggesting h takes g4
this is a classic fishing pole trap then
after
pawn takes g4
if i'm not mistaken i think this is
force mate
right yeah box made max mating in four
um because
you just can't stop queen h2 e5 you take
it
g3 you take it like the bishop is very
useful on c5
so it's a very common theme
not only in the stafford but just the
steam in general against the castle
general kenobi can lead to fun things
anyway um hopefully that answers some
people's questions
uh maybe i'll play with like one more
game to
wait but one more game in a different
tournament
have i heard of bofa i have not
i'm sometimes scared to ask
alexa very instructive
i don't have an answer for that by the
way
an amazon package was oh alexa quiet
i picked up oh actually so i picked up
um
i picked up a package and
i have like a public ups mailbox so
people want to send me fan mail
there is a mail command
um
but i was recognized at the ups
store um
i've been getting more i've been getting
like recognized more lately
from people even though i like i wear a
mask in public
uh people see through okay we're gonna
play another
another stafford i guess hopefully this
person wasn't watching the refutation
um i might have to mix things up
oh no oh this is a bit different
so white castled instead of playing h3
so i'm able to play knight g4 right away
which is kind of nice and then i play
queen d6
so threatening yeah this is different
because i had this position actually the
last game but i moved to d4 and then
back
to d6
are you serious
two games in a row
3.4 million people watched this video
but i guess not my last two opponents
two games in a row everyone still falls
for the same opening trap
that's so funny because when my
opponents started walking into this i
assume they they were watching and
and we're gonna play the refutation i
just showed but
um hi youtube
hi youtube yeah uh
i'll have to open twitch chat prime time
for twitch chat to say hi to youtube
here we go hi youtube
get some high youtube emotes if you're
watching in the future on youtube
you can follow on twitch you can
subscribe on twitch
to get the the um
the high youtube emote and then you can
say hi to yourself when you watch on
youtube in the future